[Music]
now as you've known usually there's some
meat between two slices of bread or
depending on the individual an idiot
sandwich but today i'm taking two slices
of bread and making a delicious meatball
sub
but sub the meat that's right i want to
show you how to make a delicious porcini
meatless sub in 10 minutes oscar pan
down
right
here we have some mint soy okay this is
the most amazing
delicious protein it's mince soy and
it's going to transform into a beautiful
incredible meatball
fresh mushrooms oyster mushrooms
beautiful little baguette panko
breadcrumbs garlic worcester sauce a
little bit of greek basil uh tomato from
cassay olive oil and these little babies
frozen chilies which are gonna be great
and make the sauce as we cook these
amazing porcini meatballs here's the
secret here
honestly
one little sniffer that will send you to
italy because i've got a porcini powder
which is like the secret binding agent
and literally gives it that amazing
flavor right let's have 10 minutes on
the clock here we go now
okay mince soy start off with a nice
seasoning okay salt
pepper
a little touch of chili flake okay
and
give that a little lift now how do we
bind that okay we're going to bind that
with a bit of egg a little bit of spice
in there with some worcester sauce
egg literally crack
and in she goes
okay and
from there give it a light dusting a
dusting of
this beautiful powder now
generous on it breadcrumbs in there
and from there
literally
sprinkle those breadcrumbs in there
now we bind that together
watch
now give that a really good mix
now
again
the secret behind these is making sure
that we sort of don't make the mixture
too wet too wet they won't hold together
so sort of bind it together
and then literally
pick it up it's still a touch too wet
touch more breadcrumbs in there if i had
more bread there's a little lift on the
seasoning okay just a little smashing of
olive oil in there as well
now
combined combine combined
and
that's it mix it nicely
from there literally
in
golf ball
size okay
roll it around
and then literally squeeze
nice
now look golf ball size have you been
that sometimes they'll break up but
um literally
that size
let's go for six
again
made the day before left in the fridge
they'll firm up but as you can see doing
it live
trust me
it's just as effective but
this is such a lovely way of
you know holding onto the classics but
just getting a little bit more creative
and then finally
look at that
no waste
and the only expense here of course is
that literal
porcini powder right wash the hands
now
like any sub is how you lay this up
right okay gas on beautiful nonstick pan
in with the olive oil get that nice and
hot
and i'm gonna cut up some mushrooms and
throw the mushrooms in there at the same
time
oyster mushrooms okay
beautifully done
as that pan starts to smoke
roll that down i just want to place them
in there and look
pan down please oscar
beautiful okay i use that side of the
pan says when i tip the pan it cooks the
back of those beautiful
meatballs
beautiful
a little season on top as well i like
the seasoning inside and the seasoning
on the outside okay
from there
cut up the mushrooms
throw those mushrooms in there
now it's important to get some color on
those mushrooms okay
as you know no color no flavor
now
from there
start this whole process
very gently okay
roll
those
meatballs over look at the color please
pan down please oscar
come look at that color on there it does
look like a delicious meatball
incredible
flavor on the mushrooms
a few more in there
and now how do i get those mushrooms up
into
a little bit more of a exciting flavor
take your chili
and just grate
that chili
over
and all we've got is this nice bit of
juice coming out
and this finely grated chili over those
mushrooms
look it's almost like a really nice
chili puree
garlic
speak up please
garlic and chili go beautiful with
meatballs and look for that wonderful
nice hit
our puree garlic
and puree chili in
now
how do i get the flavor in there again
how do i how do i wrap that up a little
bit of butter
we've got the color on the meatballs as
we speak
and look
the smell now those meatballs i never
thought i'd say that with a vegetarian
cosplay but they do smell delicious
garlic that chili
a few more mushrooms in there
now think about the way that we
set this up
in terms of i'm trying to make a sort of
sauce in the pan at the same time okay
so we're wasting nothing but maximizing
on our flavor
and those mushrooms got the color on
there
those meatballs are working their magic
and look
also got that color on all those
meatballs
okay i'm gonna take them out
and start my sauce
now
halfway
so
the color is on the meatball beautifully
done take them out for now i've got my
garlic and my chili and my mushrooms
okay the flavor is
incredible okay
now
look inside that pan
before it starts to go up a little okay
mushrooms in there touch more chili in
there okay
and then from there literally
add your chopped tomatoes
now fold that through
get your beautiful basil
and literally just snap off the tops
slice that up
and now we create a little bit of
perfume inside that meatball okay
look at that
beautiful the basil is tiny it's
fragrant incredibly powerful but so good
especially for this sauce and then the
magic berry dust
the porcini powder over there
i'm so happy with that
now off of the gas
and this is where we start to build out
that amazing sandwich
let's take
the ends off
let's cut straight down
the center
okay
like so open that up
now
set it on your tray now okay
set that on the tray
and then literally
yeah
we start the build and this is where
it starts to go up another level
in
with that beautiful mushrooms
and that tomato sauce is getting
literally
absorbed inside that bread
oh boy
look
time please
man
all the way down
useful
and now look
that smells delicious
one
two
three
and then finally
i grated mozzarella cheese
on
okay and then i'm just gonna literally
put that with a touch of olive oil on
top
i touch the chili and season that and
then on
the grill for the last
90 seconds here we go
boom
the flavor and the smell you can't
penalize me for the grilling time i said
ramsay in 10 so you need to cut me a
little bit slack especially for the
final moments
now get some basil and just chop that
for the end
that little bit of zest that umph and
that beautiful sweetness of that lovely
basil okay
mix that again with a touch of seasoning
and a touch of pepper so you're
seasoning your herbs and
fingers crossed
they're bubbling
look at that
come on
lift that up
up on
and there you go
an amazing meatless stuff i can't
believe i'm saying that but
it's done in ten enjoy
to all of you thank you for watching
ramsay intent if i went too quick i
apologize but slow it down now don't
forget to pick up ramsey intent cookbook
inspired by this series and trust me
you're going to come out a much better
chef and if you like this video don't
forget to subscribe to my amazing
youtube channel for more good luck